[音楽]
anglo
みなさんこんにちは
私は腹洋介と言います
私の職業は医師です
そしてへ今私は
新しい医療機器を作るための
会社を準備したりほかの事業のお手伝いをしたりしています
今日は皆さんに
現場から飛び出す勇気その大切さについてお話をさせていただきたいと思います
私が会社や事業などを手掛けているというのはこれは私にとって
目的ではありません
これは集団です
私は自分の取り組みを
同世代やもっと若い世代のいろいろな方に見ていただいて
現場から飛び出す勇気を持ってもらいたいと思います
それを通してこの東北地方をもっと元気にしていきたいと思っているのです
それでは始めに
こちらの質問をご覧下さい
あなたのやりたいことは何ですか
もし学生の方がいたら
あなたは将来どんな仕事をやってみたいですか
少し表現を変えましょう
あなたのあなたにとっての転職は何ですか
いかがでしょうか
こういった質問をみなさまはいろいろなところで聞くことがあると思います
ですが
これらの質問に対して
自信を持って答えることができたでしょうか
少なくとも私は
自信を持って答えられなかったという経験があります
またこういったことは他の方も同じように感じていると思います
これは平成27年に
仕事を辞められた方のその理由を示していますが
労働条件以外の理由として
満足のいく仕事内容ではなかったということが最も多い内容になっています
一つの仕事を継続して行うということは思いのほか難しいことなのです
それでは先ほどの質問の意味をお話する前に少し私自身のお話をさせてください
私は東北地方の小さい町で生まれ育ちました
自然の豊かなところです
これは私の祖父母の写真ですが
私の祖父が大事対戦を地元に戻り何もないところから人のためにと言って
が市の事業とガソリンの事業と翔店の経営を始めました
仕事一筋で真面目な性格の人だったんですが
ことあるごとに私に
お金のためにではなく
人のために役立つことをしなさいと
入っていました
また私の家族は
小さい頃から私に本や図鑑を買ってくれたり
興味のあることに色々と援助してくれたりして
私は
興味のある好奇心のあることに対して
知らないことを学ぶのはとても良いことが楽しいことだという体験をしてきました
これら2つのことが私の幼少期のベースになっています
そして祖父の教えを受け継いで私は人のためにと思って
医学部に進みました
そして大学を卒業後
研修医の生活が始まりました
そして順調に研修医の生活が進みあと一ヶ月になったある日
それは起こったのです
東日本大震災でした
私は当時
病院で手術をしていましたが
あまりの揺れの大きさにこれはもう助からないと感じました
また
失われていく多くの命を目の当たりにしました
そこで先ほどの質問ですが
自分のやりたいことは本当は何なのだろうか
本当にこのままでいいのだろうかと何度も自問自答しました
ですが自信を持って答えることができませんでした
私は悩みました
そして2つのことをやることに決めました
一つは
目の前のドクターとして与えられた仕事一生懸命こなすことでした
そしてもうひとつは
自分が
社会のため世のために何ができるだろうと考え
より社会に目を向けました
医学以外のことについても勉強をし始めたのです
ちょうどその頃
アメリカのスタンフォード大学で
日本とアメリカが協働して医療機器のイノベーションを起こす
起業家養成のプログラムが始まりました
私の上司が私の興味を知ってくださって
プログラムに行ってみないかと勧めてくださいました
私にとっては大きなチャンスと思い
二つ返事でプログラムに応募しました車
そしてシリコンバレーの
第一線で活躍する起業家や事業家の方と一緒に
仕事をする機会を得たのです
そのことをきっかけに
今私は
医療機器の開発や
医療分野のイノベーションそれからデザイン思考の教育などをはじめ
東北大学の中でいろいろなことに携わらせていただいています
私のこのアメリカでの体験は
非常にインパクトの大きいものでしたが
一方で周りからは
あなたは医者なのです事業を専門ではないですよね
そして
リスクが大きいのではないかと言われたり
あとは良い者が他のことをやるなんて中途半端だと言われたりしました
ですバーン
医療従事者こそが最も患者さんのために親身になって解決策を望んでいるのです
たとえ専門ではなくても
以上従事者だけで解決できない問題があったら
他の方の協力が必要です
そして
私が1人で何でもできるわけではないので
その中途半端だからこそ
逆に周りに人が集まって
チームが作れるそしてその人たちが助けてくれるということを今実感しています
この周りが助けてくれるというのはちょうど
クラウドファンディングのようなものです
多くの人がインターネットを経由して
何かをやりたいという人に協力したり
それから資金を提供したり
こういった仕組みがクラウドファンディングですが
何かをやりたいという人の
熱意を受けて
きっと周りの多くな人が
実際に協力してくれると思っています
ですので
私の最初の質問に対する回答は
一つの答えに縛られなくても良いのではないかと思っています
これは
なぜなら
その仕事ややりたいことの組み合わせこそが自分らしさ
価値になると思うんです
例えば私入れあれば
同じ診療科の専門医は
今日本に8000に言いますが
その中で医療機器のイノベーションやデザイン思考などをやっている人はとても稀だと
思います
そしてこれは
仕事だけに限らず
例えば仕事一筋でやっている方が
活躍の場所が複数あってもいいと思うんです
それから趣味や他の活動と組み合わせてもいいと思うんです
それこそが
あなたらしい答えになると思うんです
ですので
ぜひ勇気を持って
自分の世界から飛び出してみましょう
これは
学校や会社や親が言ったからではなく
あなた自身がやりたいと思うことに取り組んでみてください
私の祖父であればガソリンスタンドの経営をしてガスやをやって
商店の経営をしていましたが
それらは
地域の人たちの暮らしを豊かにすることが目標でした
私のやりたいことグループインターも
自分の取り組みを通して
他の同世代や若い人たちが
一緒になってくれて
そして東北地方をもっと元気にしていきたいと
思っています
それでは実際に何をしてみればいいでしょうか
これは
まず普段会わない人と会ってみたり
馴染みのない分野を学んでみることから始めてください
それを続けることできっと誰かがあなたに協力してくれると思います
そして今日はその最良のチャンスです
ぜひ今日から
最初の一歩を踏み出してほしいのです
ご静聴ありがとうございました車
[拍手]